lance bass has learned some shocking
news about his family tree while taking
part in ancestry's two lies and a leaf
after uh all this time it was revealed
that his sixth cousin once removed is
none other than britney spears and this
was a dream come true for lance take a
look
which
unexpected distant relative
is part of lance's musical family tree a
faith hill
b
britney spears
i wish or c
elvis presley oh those are three good
ones wait so that means i'm related to
one of these
yes
take your markers and your cards and
write in your guess i really hope it's
britney but there's no way
okay okay on the count of three i want
you to turn over your cards one
two
three
elvis hypo britney i hope it's too good
to be true and the answer is
be
freaky fears
are you
kidding me i don't care about losing
because this is amazing i know i guess
you really are the true winner here oh
my gosh wait how am i related to britney
spears britney is your sixth cousin once
removed boom
this is the look i wanted to be related
to the queen well now i'm related to the
queen of pop that is so crazy though
because i mean i feel like she's my
little sister and this whole time she's
been my little cousin she's the best
she's the best and it makes sense
because we were we were born an hour
from each other yeah i know you've told
me that this is so cool